[Musica]
una delle parole più ricorrenti una
delle parole che ho sempre udito
accostato al nome di calabria nome di
aspromonte il castigo il castigo di una
terra il castigo che spesso è divenuto
uno spasmo in crema o re una condizione
precaria per la nostra gente per i
nostri centri per i nostri borghi un
castigo che spesso si è manifestato con
le alluvioni con i terremoti con i
maremoti
insomma una forza che spesso si è
opposta e ha soffocato il respiro della
umanità che spesso ne ha arrestato il
suo cammino per questo è un emblema di
uno dei nostri tanti paesi in calabria
in questo caso d'aspromonte che ci ha
fatto capire come spesso la nostra
storia e privazione sottrazione mancanza
ma vi è un altro castigo con il quale io
sono entrato in contatto nel momento in
cui ho cominciato a occuparmi della
natura e delle sue espressioni delle sue
diverse manifestazioni alla guida di un
ente dello stato e questa volta non era
la natura imprimere la sua stima
questa volta era stato l'uomo le ultime
generazioni hanno impresso un peccato un
nuovo castigo e questo ne è l'emblema
nella pietra cappa una sostanza minerale
una roccia che caratterizza identifica
fortemente la nostra montagna
d'aspromonte ma che fu anche il
nascondiglio ancora privazione della
vita ancora sottrazione della libertà fu
la pietra sotto cui fu tenuto in
ostaggio
il primo uomo sequestrato in aspromonte
bene ma quando io ho pensato alla nostra
regione al nostro aspromonte
difficilmente ho voluto immaginare a
questo castigo
ho pensato che si dovesse superare
sorpassare un istante della storia e
allora ho chiesto una volta durante il
mio cammino ad una persona quanto è
giusto che duri un castigo e cosa
occorre fare per cancellarlo
e poi ancora una terra un luogo uno
spazio che io abito può avere un peccato
può portare con sé un castigo
beh mi fu risposto che per soffocare un
castigo
occorre elevare una preghiera ma io non
sono un apostolo
io non so innalzare preghiere al cielo
io so pregare come ciascuno di voi può
fare nella propria intimità
eppure c'è una parola forse una tenda e
più belle parole che è contenuta nel
nostro vocabolario che è cultura in
quella parola io vi ho trovato i termini
e gli accenti di una preghiera nella sua
accezione nella sua ambivalenza
coltivare per coltivare in fondo è
affidare ad un altro qualcosa si coltiva
la terra io affido un seme alla terra
spero che quel seme si trasformi in
altra sostanza che porti frutto che io
possa tenere tra le mie mani
beh in questo atto che un atto
discendente da l'uomo verso la terra vi
è una preghiera e cultura e nella
preghiera biella attesa
vi è la speranza che le cose si compia
beh allora un contadino è un uomo di
cultura un pastore è un uomo di cultura
nella misura in cui sa affidare qualcosa
di sé ad un'altra entità in questo caso
la terra per attendere che qualcosa si
trasporti ma cultura è anche ciò con cui
spesso gli eruditi mostrano di sé la
loro conoscenza la cultura questa volta
ci indica un atto ascendente invece
tendere verso qualcosa di auto verso una
conoscenza superiore
beh ma anche in quel caso io vi ho
intravisto il termine l'accento di una
preghiera anche nell'uomo erudito
soprattutto se accosta alla conoscenza
anche la fiducia di una intelligenza
superiore
ecco la preghiera affidare ad un altra
entità e anche in questo caso attendere
dunque io ho visto nel semplice
nell'udito la sintesi è il compendio di
ciò che io andavo cercando e ho
camminato con i pastori per comprendere
come loro avrebbero atteso le loro
istanze e nello stesso tempo ho
camminato con gli eruditi con i filosofi
o coloro che sapevano insegnarmi
qualcosa per capire come attendere in
quel caso che si compisse il termine e
il tè di un progetto
ecco da qui è nata un'alleanza se c'è
qualcosa che mi ha suggerito il termine
cultura è l'alleanza la fiducia
l'incontro tra le cose essenziali
primordiali della natura i suoi istinti
mobili le sue capacità di comunicare
come ci ha detto prima
massimiliano e allora in questa immagine
ho voluto
rappresentare questa alleanza
primordiale vedetevi è in questo caso
impressa una intelligenza nativa che
quasi si propone una intelligenza umana
che è pronta ad offrire le spalle a
lasciare la scena l'intelligenza nativa
e poi vi è un intelligenza altra che in
quella preghiera in quell'attesa io
chiamai intelligenza superiore che in
questo caso è nell'intelligenza di colui
che ha impresso lo stampo che ha
lasciato le cose così come sono così
come venivano offerte all'osservazione
beh è chiaro che qualsiasi cosa noi si
pensi delle idee di un progetto per
cambiare la nostra terra per cancellare
quel peccato
occorre mettersi in cammino corro
individuare un sentiero emettere un
passo dietro l'altro con fiducia e anche
questa è un'altra parola che prendo in
prestito da massimiliano la fiducia beh
mettersi in cammino per incontrare la
bellezza la bellezza è una cura e la
bellezza supera il dramma albaro come
voi tutti sapete amava dire qualcosa
della nostra terra dell'aspromonte in
particolare e ne definiva le sue diverse
connotazioni le sue diverse
caratteristiche con una frase che mi ha
sempre continua ancora a farmi
riflettere
l'aspromonte è drammatica bellezza come
se volesse suggerire egli stesso con
questa frase già la soluzione del dramma
la drammatica bellezza viene superata
l'accezione del dramma con il termine
del
il tempo e il modo le dimensioni che
regolano le ri pensioni che possono
risolvere i greci intendevano il tempo
con due differenti termini kronos e il
tempo che scorre con le lancette del
nostro orologio e quel cronometro che mi
impone l'ordine che mi impone di
scandire le parole entro uno spazio
temporale assegnato
beh kronos il dramma kronos e il peccato
kronos e il castigo kronos e tutto ciò
che è contingente ma i greci per
indicare il tempo in un modo anche molto
più creativo pieno e compiuto
utilizzavano il termine kairos kairos
per i greci era il tempo delle cose che
si compiono e dunque io intravedo in
questa dimensione del tempo in kairos
ancora una volta l'esito di una
preghiera che è attesa che è speranza
che qualcosa cambi si trasformi si
compia questa immagine vi fa vedere
allora l'emblema del peccato
nel contingente pietra cup quella pietra
che tenne nascosta la vita e poi vedete
un tempo che è quello del movimento
degli astri dei corpi celesti molto più
lungo ma qui rappresentato in un istante
ecco vedete questa volta celeste per
costa da queste traiettorie circolari e
così che io voglio immaginare il tempo
per la nostra terra una traiettoria
circolare che a un certo punto lascia la
sua origine si proietta in avanti
dimenticando le cose che la
hanno afflitta e che l'hanno trafitta da
allora se pensiamo che sia kairos e non
kronos a muovere i nostri passi
e se pensiamo che la cultura possa
essere quella preghiera che soffoca ogni
peccato possiamo immaginare di avere un
sogno è ancora una volta mi fa piacere
accostarmi al massimiliano come a
volerne ricercare una guida in questo
mio dire un sogno da camminare e quello
che abbiamo cercato di fare coinvolgendo
quella umanità semplice non l'erudito ma
il pastore accompagnandoci con lui
abbiamo fatto nascere la famosa figura
dell'eco pastore a cui abbiamo affidato
la nostra montagna abbiamo affidato la
nostra natura la sua protezione la sua
tutela
sono nate dieci cooperative di giovani
in aspromonte tuttora impegnate nel
contesto della natura della tutela
ambientale e poi abbiamo accostato le
due grandi dimensioni che caratterizzano
la nostra regione la nostra provincia il
nostro aspromonte in particolare quella
natura è quella cultura che sono in
grado di mescolare le sostanze la
sostanza minerale dell'aspromonte la sua
sostanza liquida e terranea e poi la
sostanza umana di eruditi e di semplici
e sono pronti a mettersi in cammino
abbiamo anche voluto creare una rete la
rete come sistema intelligente di
relazioni in questo caso dei musei delle
cose più preziose che noi possediamo e
che possiamo portare innanzi e poi quell
emblema del peccato quella pietra cappa
può diventare ed è diventato l'emblema
invece di una candidatura planetaria
tutti voi sanno che abbiamo candidato
l'aspromonte la montagna d'aspromonte a
global geopark unesco una candidatura
mondiale planetaria inaspettata per le
modalità e per i tempi con la quale con
i quali è stata avanzata proposta è
accettata il racconto questa brevissima
esperienza si teneva il convegno
internazionale per la presentazione
delle candidature dei parchi nazionali
di tutto il mondo per valutare quali
fossero maturi e meritevoli di poter
accedere a questa rete planetaria non
avevamo alcun alcuna scaletta che
prevedeva il nostro intervento quando
attraverso una azione un po audace prima
che cominciassero i lavori
io chiesi al moderatore di poter
proiettare un paio di immagini nella
nostra montagna d'aspromonte per poterla
presentare al mondo è l'immagine che
diedi e che feci mettere nel computer
era proprio l'immagine di pietra cappa
un certo punto con sorpresa il
presidente mondiale dei global geopark
unesco incuriosito da questo monir
monolite dai sembianti quasi animaleschi
disse ma cos'è questa fu invitato a
salire sul palco
e allora disse allora chiamiamo qui il
presidente del parco nazionale
dell'aspromonte giuseppe bombino che ci
spieghi cosa è questa immagine bene mi
alzai dal mio posto stavo per
raggiungere il palco così come ho fatto
questa sera ea quel punto il mio collega
di sedia
il presidente di un parco nazionale in
gran bretagna i se o aspromonte mind de
rang età attenzione alla ndrangheta
dunque la ndrangheta si stava alzando
per raggiungere il parco la ndrangheta
era rappresentata da quella immagine da
pietra cappa che in quei giorni anche
era stata rappresentata ostentata anche
da alcune testate giornalistiche
nazionali
ecco qual era la nostra percezione ecco
perché il peccato spesso rappresenta per
noi una stima ecco perché noi dobbiamo
elevare questa preghiera si conclusero i
lavori fu invitato a fare una relazione
a valle di questi lavori fu accettata la
proposta di candidatura non la
candidatura la proposta di candidatura
del parco nazionale d'aspromonte a
global geopark unesco da lì si avviò
un'esperienza bellissima che ci vide poi
unico parco italiano e secondo d'europa
candidato poi con successo a questa
vetrina planetaria
e i nostri giovani hanno poi costituito
questa rete a cui si faceva riferimento
prima hanno cominciato a camminare per
l'aspromonte invitando i turisti hanno
cominciato ad interessarsi della ricerca
hanno realizzato una mountain bike per
terreni accidentati integralmente
progettata disegnata ad eccezione delle
componenti
tecnologiche da ragazzi quindi anche i
raggi delle ruote di questa bicicletta
sono stati disegnati progettati e
realizzati dai ragazzi hanno cominciato
a infrastrutturare dolcemente
l'aspromonte hanno cominciato a metterne
in sicurezza dei versanti più precari
hanno contribuito al raggiungimento
delle emergenze naturalistiche
archeologiche e geologiche anche a chi
non si muove con la nostra stessa
facilità quella che tra k è diventato il
punto di osservazione planetario da cui
l'aspromonte finalmente può comunicare
il suo vero nome non più un nome ruvido
alla pronuncia ma un nome dolce così
come noi vorremmo ricordare grazie
[Applauso]